well my White House chief strategist
Steve Bannon is speaking out about one
of the president prompts most
controversial decisions in office last
night on 60 minutes we spoke to venom in
his first extensive interview since he
left the White House and part of the
interview you have not seen Bannon
explain why he was against the firing of
former FBI director James Comey it has
been reported that Jared Kushner was in
favor of firing James Comey is that
correct I have you guys have to have to
find that out either through the media
or through the investigation I don't
know it is also true
many say and you're a smart guy that if
James Comey had not been fired we would
not have the Muller investigation true I
don't think there's anything I don't
think I don't think there's any doubt
that if James Comey had not been fired
we would not have a special counsel yes
it would not have the Muller
investigation would not have the mole
investigation would not have the mole
investigation in the breath that clearly
mr. molar is going do you believe is I
think it's a very directional I think
directional eyes are very different you
believe mr. Muller should be fired no I
do not
has it been discussions in the White
House about firing him I would not tell
you about discussions in the White House
but I would tell you I never heard like
that someone said to me that you
described the firing of James Comey
you're a student of history as the
biggest mistake in political history
that would be probably that probably be
too bombastic even for me but maybe
modern political history
so the firing of James Comey was the
biggest mistake in modern political
history if you're saying that that's
associated with me then I'll leave it at
that or from the interview tonight on my
PBS program
irma gives a rare because he was so I
thought so candid he was the way he
talked about Mitch McConnell the way he
talked about Paul Ryan Gary Cohen
declared war on them he really did try
I'm wondering what the working
relationship is going to be in the White
House after that and I thought it gave
us insight as to how the White House
works
and how much access I still feel it
seems that he still has to Donald Trump
I think he does I think there's a bad
relationship between Donald Trump and
him know why he left he said he would
plan to leave others have reported that
he was fired he said he plan to leave
and he chose the date and he told the
chief of staff that yeah he made it
clear he wasn't pushed out but at one
point did you see it nor it got so
intense when you were talking about
Charlotte so he was clenching his jaws
so hard that it started pulsating do you
remember that yeah I did see it it was
very very graphic I was wondering what
was going on in that moment because you
two had such great back-and-forth
give-and-take
I think he was just trying to answer the
questions or not answer them yeah one of
the other he's he's a very interesting
guy whatever you think of him and what
he said he's a very interesting guy and
and we had a chance to ask a lot of the
questions that I wanted to ask him
answered and as we have said this is the
only tentative television interview
well Beyonce has a song where she says
bow down and it's her way of saying all
hail the Queen I think many people I'm
getting calls about the interview people
congratulating me I got nothing to do
with it people are saying all hail the
king that was a amazing interview well
first and we'll only one of its kind
well thing thanks no that's a good way
to put it but I think so